SENATOR RANDAND ENN
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI WASPLAY.
>> SO, SENATOR PAUL USED HISE T
DR. T THINE
, VIROLO
SUPPORT FUND T NOF THE LAB IHAOL
NTIRELY AND LY INCORRECT THAT TD
>>BAR RACK? N
>> WE
>> DU FUND BARRETT?
GUIDELINES, ANITINCONDUCTED IN N
NOT . STILL SUPPORT
SENDING MONETO
>> SEND MONEY -- WR YOUR TUTEL.
WE WERSE THROUGH OHEALTH.
IT WAS SUB AGEANB
GRAN
WUHAN INSTITUTE -- H THAT WA
ATAS
T
BATS I
OF U WE DID NOINBAT VIRUS E LOGY
S HE
ED IN A.
R PERHAPS IT WE SIBLE TO SEND I
CHINESE GOVERN TRUST WITH THIS
FUNCTION RESEARCH IN CHINA.R'TNF
YOU ARYING THINGS THAT ARE
NOT
LET'SRI ICNN
POLITICAL ANT ,
COLUMNISFO
AN MEMBGOVERN BDOCTORS, SO
LET'S START RE WITH JU
WHY THIS WAS THE CENTE
PAUL.
>> RIGHT.ERE'S AN
F LAAKOTSIDES OF THE AISLE
WHO ARE TRYING OWAS S FOR TH
RELATIONSHIP TWUHAN LABS AND T R
ICL HAT'S GAIN OF
RCH, WHAT THAT
INS FRHE
WINDERIMENTS THAT . I SAIDEREARE
IN WUHAN S ASOFCTN CH ANDL WAS
R SCIENTISTS THINK IT F YOU TAKI
DEBATE, WHAT'SE
TE ANDAGAIN, BOTH PARTIES
ARTR IO E
RELATIONSHN H
DR. FAUCANE WUHAN LABS
POLITICSUT BOTTO IS G CAUGHT UPE
THERE'S INCREASING CLSISORTING
OR A YEA
TO THE REST OF YOU WASA F WONKY
>> T
SPOHEALT, AS HE , DID IGHTFA
NOT GO T THEROAN IMIC THAT W
F AND HISDERV
I IN QUESTION THESLA TO TO, AND
IMATE ESTION, TO B
ON THINK
THEY'RE ALSO POLITICINAND THAT R
BECAUSE IT'S NOT A POLITIC.
YOKNOW, WE NEED TO FIND OUHON
ORDER TO PREVENT THE NEXT ONE,
AND  TE NEED
TO KNOW MORE ABOUT THELAFAUCI'S
NITE
THE TRUTH AND YES, FCIBOUT GETTI
PER AT THE ECOHEALLL
VAW OSEEN RESISTING THESE
EFFORTS ARE EASING AND IT'S
TTLITTLE WHICH,
AD BECAUSE IT
LDN'T E ABOUT
THE TB, IF
THAT STARTS WITHUT IT
ALSO INCLUDES LOOKING AT OUR OWN
RELATIONSHIPS AND OUOWN LAURSE,O
TO THE ANSWER.
LI
2021 AND STILHAW IS
ORSTIGATION,
RE ANY IND THEILOVRENISTRATION'
GOALFIW THIS ARTED OR IS THIS OH
S ILY? YOU KNOW, VICTOR, THAT'II
ND EVERYBODY WHO'S B
FOLLOWINTHWST'HEAND
IT'S REALLY HARD TO TIZE
HAT I TELL YOU FROMY
AN
DEN ADMINISTRATION IS
KIERY HARD LOOK  SAW A HANHAT
Y SO NTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY IS TH
STTI TO EY'RE TRNG
THEY HAVEN'T FIGURED OUT HOW TOU
WEEKS.ILL BY NENDEZ AND SENATOR
DETET LEASE THIN
ANTHY BLINKEN AND  N, UT FAUCI ,
SUIV ALL ISEEMS
LIKE IT SHOU BE RELEASED AND E O